right thank you
Alistair talked about our partition
functions yesterday
I am also talking about partition
functions but maybe more combinatorial
vu said I'm not sort of striving to get
the most general definition but the
reasonably broad definition of this
father say suppose that we have a family
of subsets some criminally defined
family of subsets
and what we do we associate a polynomial
with it in principle in M complex
variables so we take the sum over all
subsets in the family and the product
over elements in the subset of the
variables sort of a generating function
and the reason we call the partition
function so what we want from it so
typically typically in interest in
situations so this set the family is
pretty large and therefore it's a bad
idea to try to write this polynomial
explicitly as a sum of monomials but on
the other hand it's sort of clearly
defined so checking
[Music]
whether particular subset in the family
is immediate is easy and what we want to
do we want to compute maybe
approximately this polynomial whenever
we can
and of course our questions are why but
that I'm planning to impress only
briefly later it makes a living so you
can think of a good example as for
example if I have a draft and with an
edges and the family is just a family of
all Plutonian cycles in the graph say
financially it's a large family but
checking if any particular set of edges
for male form a Hamiltonian cycle is
easy and we want to compute it whenever
we can all right so that's the partition
function as like to think about it
sections
right so then I'll be talking about the
relation of the computational complexity
of the operation function and its
complex zeros and I'd like to have one
running example so it's sort of my
long-held superstition that whatever
method you get you should try it on the
permanent and if it doesn't give you
anything new
then scrap it and just start thinking
about something else so what's the
permanent said it's also introduced last
time so the matrix would have a square
matrix a a IJ and by a matrix so the
permanent of a is the sum over all our
permutations which there and factorial
all the products
generalize diagonals so it looks like
the determinant only simpler so there
are no signs and it was introduced that
same year I think in the same paper is
the determinant smartest by benign
caffeine 1812 it was a fateful year in
many respects in particular the
permanent appeared so ok so again so if
we try to write it so it sort of fits
this general description we know what a
permutation is right and if we try to
write it explicitly I'll take us awhile
right for even for moderate values
so then I'd like to have a sort of to
start the description of the results so
I'll say two theorems one is called
theorem 1 and the others theorem 2 and
I'll spend some time explaining why one
implies the other so theorem 1 so let a
be n by n complex matrix complex matrix
such that all entries within distance
point 5 from 1 I J so the picture is as
follows so we have interest in that disk
round 1 so then
the permanent of a zero so I like to
remark here that it should not be
immediately obvious because if for
example all the entries of the matrix
are the same and just line this circle
somewhere here then the permanence is
roughly n factorial times a to the N so
as this entry walks in the circle it
potentially can rotate n times almost n
times around the origin but it will
never hit it because when you rotate the
first rotate n times one way but then it
will rotate M time saw the way so that
one in number was zero so and if at any
point already you got bored I challenge
you to prove it it uses some middle
school math I'll prove it at the end and
as you doing it I challenge you even
further to improve that point five I
don't know if it's optimal I know for
example that square root of 2 over 2
cannot be here
here in one theorem two will be implied
by hearing one and it will say that as
long as you tighten this condition a bit
then things become computable so for
every and every epsilon J between zero
and one there is a polynomial P of a
which I understand is a polynomial in N
squared matrix entries J such that
on the degree of B is logarithmic so is
maybe I should just write all notation
we're all implied constants here in our
notation are absolute right and
if I try to approximate the log of the
permanent by that polynomial it ends up
being within absolute error epsilon
provided
the matrix satisfies slightly tighter
conditions saying the distance from one
is at most point four nine days so
basically the the the essence of the
argument is to explain how is first one
implies the second one and so this
polynomial is not mysterious at all so
we'll compute it so if explicitly or at
least give some recipe for that
so it's computable in again in
quasi-polynomial time so P is computable
in and log n minus log AB sometime
and we had this rainforest was aleister
yesterday saying that no for me a closet
fallen on oh well for you is not so then
I didn't know how to make it okay so so
the the first goal therefore will be to
explain this implication objections to
that so that application will have some
universal significance it really have
nothing to do with a permanence so so
the general principle here that are
advertised
is that if this partition function
is nonzero
in some complex domain
in right then it can be efficiently
computed in a smaller domain slightly
smaller
on the other thing that I have to say is
that so I'm taking the log and allow the
matrix to be complex and this is alright
because by this theorem I know that the
permanence is nonzero so I can choose
the continuous branch of the login that
I simply connected domain
so again any any objections so you also
need something easy starting point in
that sort of right but that's negative
alright so what do we mean by easy so
you say it's easy I'll say it's not so
it's certainly it's not a theorem right
it's a principle
so I allowed to be intentionally vague
okay so computed but nicely approximated
by Taylor series well we'll see about
that
so it's start with Taylor series but
then it'll do something else
so right
so in all
well it is but I'm approximating its and
of course I mean it's known that it's a
result of jerem Sinclair regatta that
it's approximable for know- matrices its
approximable for some other matrices in
particular for this one although I'm not
claiming you computed exactly that still
remains sharp be hard because if you
computed exactly in an open domain then
just by interpolation you can compute
exactly everywhere right so it soaking
just on the lemma just not much say
trivial but useful remark so the lanlan
ghost as follows so let G be a
univariate polynomial of degree N and it
so happens that it's nonzero in a disk
of radius greater than one centered at
the origin for some beta strictly
greater than one so the picture again is
we have a disk and there are no zeros
here
right and the radius is greater than one
so then what I can do because again it's
a simply connected domain I can take the
log and it's an analytic functional
right and I will approximate it by
Taylor series computed at zero so I'll
say that take the Taylor polynomial
Jessie series polynomial of degree M
bottom computed and isay row
and what I would what I want to do I
want to use this Taylor polynomial to
approximate the value of that function
at one and I can do that so if I try to
approximate really at one then I can
write a bound so that does not exceed
the degree n divided by beta to the M
beta minus 1 and we don't factor of M
plus 1 not terribly important here but
what is important is that to get
error epsilen
it suffice us to pick the polynomial of
degree of logarithmic in an and absent
the prices have something like that so M
of the order of beta certainly comes way
here what also log and and epsilon kind
of common in look I rhythmically and
that's the same log honest here and
that's the same log epsilon as there
right so this is it right and I'll prove
it so the reasoning and all-seeing it's
not mine every dog should have one proof
in one joke and they better be not the
same what here is the distinction is
blurred so sorry for joke proof but I'll
do it so what happens here is that so
it's a polynomial right so degree n so
we can factor it so G of Z is G of 0
times the product and factors one one is
the over officer by where
alpha 1 alpha n are the roots
so if they are the roots then we know
that they don't line in that disk so
therefore they have the EZ ups as well
the greater than beta soon
I can I could have taken I hope so then
what is f of Z so f of Z I take the log
and that's F of 0 plus logs all these
fractions and what I know I know that I
know how to approximate log of 1 minus
something as the by a Taylor polynomial
so I'll say that actually if I want to
do it at 1 right so log of 1 minus 1
over officer by right is what is the if
I write the Taylor polynomial
plus if I caught it the tail series at
em so there will be error and you see
this office R in the denominator so the
error is bounded by whatever I get from
the rest of this series and it decreases
exponentially so I can estimate it by
I basically bounded by geometric series
so the point is that the error for logs
decreases exponentially and then I just
add up all errors and I get them in the
numerator I get the degree of the
polynomial
didn't do much so any name any
objections
so then I'd like to explain this this
implication where do I do that so have
this board right so implication so what
I do
I'll just define a polynomial so G of Z
a univariate polynomial so that will be
the permanent the interpolating between
the permanence of something really
simple
the permanent of the matrix field by
one's loss so Z times the matrix a minus
the matrix of all ones
so that what I want I want the value at
1 which is the permanent of the matrix
so what I knew so I know that if my
matrix satisfies the static condition
then by hearing 1 which I didn't prove
what I intend to do so I have that G of
Z is not 0 if Z does not exceed the
ratio of 0.5 over 0.49 which I call beta
and which is greater than 1 right so if
I know that my matrix the entries don't
deviate by more than 4.9 then if Z is in
that disk so the entries of this matrix
inside the permanent do not deviate from
1 by more than 0.5 and the permanent is
not 0 so then of course I use lemma and
say that so I define the log make a
continuous branch then everyone yes
so for
the disk and I'd like to approximate
that log by the Taylor polynomial I get
that the value at one which is local to
permanent is approximated by the Taylor
polynomial F computed at zero degree M
at one I'm sorry one the Taylor
polynomial starts off at zero but I want
to tell it one does not exceed absol if
for some evil that I only need
logarithmically many terms so my goal is
basically to show that this polynomial
is essentially low degree polynomial in
the entrance of the matrix which is sort
of easy so so need to show
this value is a polynomial of degree so
and I show that in two steps so the
first step one is to show that the
derivatives of the polynomial zero which
I will not use by I use the derivative
of log are polynomials and then to
figure out that the derivatives of the
law girls polynomials so what is the
value of the case derivative at zero so
if I honestly right what am I doing here
so I differentiate eight times the
permanent which is just the the sum over
all symmetric group of all permutations
of the product 1 plus Z a I Sigma of I
and well it's easy to differentiate the
somme right you just edit and it's a bit
harder but still doable to differentiate
the product depend of M terms so and I
wanted at Z equals 0 which is essential
so what I get I get the sum over all
ordered k topples right all the products
so if I substitute
so a I won Sigma Phi 1 minus 1 1 and
this song of course over all the
symmetric group but the point is that
it's a highly symmetric expression so
what it boils down to basically boils
down to some simple some say over two
sets of watered a couples right with the
free bill factor here and what I get
here is the basically particular
polynomial of degree of degree K right
so that what I get at 0 so for the
polynomial but I do need derivatives of
the log and I learned that as I go down
you can still see it on the side screen
side screens right so I'll go under yeah
I said it's not that I'm doing something
ulterior there her rank so you can still
see F prime F is a log F prime is G
prime over G so G prime is f prime times
G so if I differentiate K minus times so
I'll get a system of equations so G the
derivative at 0 is the sum from J equals
0 to K minus 1 I guess right K minus 1
choose
J and here I have F game one is j0 j0
and as Alastair explained last time
yesterday so that's just a
non-degenerate system triangular system
of linear equations so from that it
follows that and the step two it follows
that the logarithmic derivatives are
also
Oh degree okay in a IJ so that will be
step two and that concludes the proof
set right so that's a connection so I
should say that under grade students
some time ago my control each hand booth
so they performed a numerical
experiments and they kind of told me
that for matrices satisfying this
condition they checked twenty by twenty
because that's where they could compare
the answer with what maple gives exact
computation so polynomials of degree
three they said they told me give pretty
good make do pretty good job like
approximating within one percent but a
photo log and they run it like four
matrices up two hundred but there they
couldn't of course typically compare the
answer was the correct one so why do I
bring it up just to say that unlike some
other theorems this theorem is true
not only in general but also in
particular you can actually use it to
compute
right so so I suggest we look at it for
40 seconds and see if there any any
issues here yeah so that turns out to be
pretty hard because even 3x3 matrices
the maple already hiccups so it's very
easy to show that for example the
permanent of the matrix 1 plus I over 2
1 plus I over 2 1 minus I over 2 1 minus
I over 2 is 0 so therefore 0.5 cannot be
replaced by square root of 2 over 2
which is 4 in sound but and furthermore
you can construct examples like this
that's Marie's book did of an
arbitrarily large size so square root of
2 over 2 is there to stay but a
colleague of mine John Stan bridge found
a matrix which I call the gene matrix so
it's XY y YX y YY X for some particular
values Y and X which say that point 5 in
this case can it be replaced
by 0.69 but but but this one doesn't
scale so we don't know there are analogs
of it like in high dimensions so in fact
we know nothing well sort of what's on
this board so for example I don't even
know if the exact task that should come
with a strict inequality non-strict for
every particular M of course it should
come with a non strict inequality right
because right is closed but as I'm gross
so the in quality may or may not become
strict and furthermore I don't know what
kind of mathematics can you possibly use
to figure out you even that question so
if the inequality is strict in the limit
or industry I'll let alone if point 5 is
a bad story
I know you have other techniques than
all the entries are real yes I'll do it
right now yeah does this it's built on
this one remarks
so now I'm going to erase here in one in
theorem two and put theorem 3 and
theorem for
theorem cream theorem 3 says that 3 says
that I can allow set a greater range for
real parts of a IJ provided I pinch the
the Imogen report so right so fix
some delta between 0 and 1 and the
interesting case is not of a small Delta
but the one close to 1 and let AJ be a
complex matrix such that the entry the
real parts of the entries within Delta
from 1 about the imagery parts are
pinched something like that will do so
for all IJ so interesting case when
Delta is close to 1 right so then the
permanent is not 0 from that all deduce
our theorem for
which says the following so fix zero fix
Delta between zero and one again the
interesting case goes to one then for
any absolute any one any end there is a
polynomial in the entries of an N by n
matrix J such that the degree is still
logarithmic and the implied constant in
all o notation is absolute and the log
of the permanent approximated by that
polynomial with an absolute provided
the entries are real and are in between
I guess I should say one minus Delta and
1 plus Delta right 1 minus 1 plus Delta
1 minus Delta so if I draw a
range for possible entry so they make
honest approach ever truly close to zero
but fixed distance from zero like
between point one and I don't know one
so what it basically says that the
matrix was positive entries where the
ratio between the smallest and the
largest is bounded away
y is bounded from above by an absolute
constant so then it's approximable oh I
wish so it's more like this yeah so we
just posed yeah but I said fix right so
that's I wanted to sweep that under the
rug that badly depends on the all-time
okay so any objections to this and I'm
going to explain the connection as I
erase this
any
any objections
so that's a realization of this promise
that the domain doesn't have to be
circular so what I do I still define
this polynomial but now I don't know if
it's nonzero in a disk about what I do
know it's nonzero in the neighborhood
zero one interval picture and no zeroes
here
I'm prepared to deal with the disc but
how do I deal with with the domain
that's not round so what I do I just
squeeze around domain there's a
construct and that's kind of an exercise
with a hint that you have construct an
auxilary not a total a large degree Z
such that it Maps 0 to 0 1 to 1 and it
Maps the disc of some radius some radius
beta greater than 1
the disk inside the neighborhood and I
can do that
this beta will not be great so beta will
be 1 plus really really small number
into the O 1 over Delta and you can show
that you cannot do better
that's a homework exercise its uses
Schwarz lemma so that's the best you can
do actually under the circumstances so
and then apply let me draw a disk here
so then and then apply
dilemma that are still there I'll put it
in bloom to the polynomial to the
composition the G of G of Z so what what
does it buy it buys you it gives you a
polynomial that's currently nonzero in
the disk over radius greater than one
you still want the value of this
polynomial at one right because it's
well auxiliary polynomial maps one to
one can you compute all the necessary
derivatives at zero yes you can because
this polynomial maps zero to zero and
therefore if you look at the composition
so that you compute like the case
coefficient the case derivative at zero
you need to know only the first K
coefficients of this so you cannot get
lower degree terms from a high degree
because here zero zero transforming this
domain tedious right right this is in a
different approach where you distribute
then you put a sequence of physics alone
yes that's what Eldar mehriban did and
that was noble and I'll show you an
example saying that this one is better
okay
yeah so so so so try to paint by disc is
the first impulse right which in my
considered opinion should be fought this
is really squeezed thanks unleash the
power of complex analysis right here
quiz and domains
okay so so let's see so I still have
like thought we didn't waste on five
minutes right till the first break
that's right yeah yeah
let me just make my case
why look in that traffic maps is a good
idea right so basically what we're after
so let me erase something
so right so what we have the following
situation so we have zero things are
easy we have one there that's what we
want in principle we could have a some
complicated path leading 0 to 1 and what
we know is that there is some
neighborhood there the polynomial is
nonzero for all in the neighborhood then
we can interpolate where I can
interpolate just like we did here and
it's pretty clear that the large of the
neighborhood would have well the larger
disk we can squiz so here we have one
extreme example where the neighborhood
is just a tiny little neighborhood of 0
1 interval here's another good example
extreme on the other side
suppose that we know that all roots are
real and negative so and suppose we know
that this distance is Delta so real
rooted thing and that connection with
other topics of this workshop then the
neighborhood we can take is just the
whole plane without that negative ray so
then the disc we can choose
you can choose beta equal one plus one
over square root of this distance and
that's done how it's done it's done it's
an exercise there is a rational map
which does that and the lemma applies to
rational maps just as well as polynomial
so what does it buy you so for example
let's look at the matching polynomial
where you thought that nothing you can
be really sad about right so matching
polynomial
so it was introduced in several shapes
and sizes and the one I like is what's
introduced by Alistair yesterday so we
have a graph and matching polynomial
the song from K equals zero to say half
of the number vertices M sub K of G
that's matching Swiss K the number of
machines with K edges
I lit up a minute or two from the
exercises times Z to the K right and the
hamon leap theorem to state it here a
number of times the roots are real and
they do not exceed what a negative 1
over 4 Delta minus 1 the Delta is max
degree in this setting right so what
this interpolation does squeeze in a
really large disk into that it gives the
following which are a result which I
found here is that within
relative error absalom the number the
number of matchings of all matchings
which is just the value of that
polynomial at one is determined by very
first few coefficients is determined by
M sub K the number of matchings with
okay edges for K which is o of 1 over
alpha naught 1 over so square root of
the largest degree times the log of the
number of vertices divided by option
so if you tell me all these numbers up
to roughly log of the number vertices
and square root of the largest degree I
can tell you with an error apps on the
number of all matchings tell you
efficiently if you tell me these numbers
and this square root of Delta I believe
is the same square root of Delta which
appears in the correlation decay
approach of the morning
God's totally paper so and my reason for
the square root here is because when you
have such a huge neighborhood you can
really squeeze the large disk into it so
I do believe that this is the best you
can do
although I don't have a proof but I do
believe that the proof can be saurons
augur says can be found if you pay a bit
and allocate some sometimes that right
so it's doable I believe yeah I believe
that so so what happens here because the
neighborhood is so huge so the this map
of the disk so if it opens up like in
like a fan and goes around this negative
ray so it covers everything
bark the negative ray
and I don't think you can do it by
paling so my belief that by paving you
don't get square root you just get one
because from a pain point of view it
doesn't matter whether roots are real or
they just lie in the left-half plane but
from sort of conformal point of view it
matters because you can do things there
is a lot of room ok so that's probably a
good time to remark about we have fun in
the break ok